colden triangles that float almost
weightlessly in space they're the heart
of the saphenous in 'tikka' exhibition
at the made gallery in Berlin the
kinetic sculpture moves like a
marionette in six minutes sequences the
curved aluminium strips on this
sculpture project an interplay of light
and shadow onto the wall
if insurance early I like this
combination of light and music and the
way it affects me two dozen his attire
three or four minutes these triangle
stands with each other it's fabulous
even though it's incredible that you can
move analog objects this way like an
organic animal it's amazing acha fun yo
la consulta is the creative force behind
the kinetic sculptures at his agency art
and calm the computer is the most
important tool the Berlin exhibition
features some of his best installations
Christina ocean veins and the pieces on
display in the exhibition are all
prototypes and installations on show
around the world HD become because
they're large and difficult to move you
can't get them all in one place so we
said we'd make prototypes and put them
in one space showing I'm home some of
the originals have won awards like this
commissioned work for BMW it earned art
on calm the German government's design
award in 2010 in 2012 the media artists
developed the idea further at singapore
airport 1,200 copper teardrop shapes
combined to form an aeroplane for the
exhibition in berlin yo atoms alter has
collaborated with a composer for the
first time Icelandic musician all other
art nerds wrote a symphony to accompany
the sculptures movements
one piece is this piano line and another
piece can be this string melody and
individually they work because they're
both characters but together they dance
together and together they become the
symphony the exhibition marks the 25th
anniversary of art and cons founding
with the rise of the Internet the agency
has implemented a number of virtual
projects now they're taking a more
tangible approach
give me a little bit the more we find
ourselves in this virtual world the more
there's a need to come together in the
real world for instance in a museum in
mind and to experience information or
entertainment together with a hydrometer
living yo a consulta is already planning
the next installation which will be in
Washington
up to 50 employees help realize the
large-scale projects such as this
mirrored wall for the 2010 world expo in
shanghai as varied as the projects are
they all fascinate and enchant viewers